RNA seek data are used to study which
genes in an organism are expressed under
different conditions RNA seek data also
provide an estimate of relative gene
expression levels within a single sample
however when RNA seek data are initially
obtained the data are simply a
collection of sequence information with
no genomic context we do not know which
genes are expressed and at what levels
in this video we will discuss the
computational approaches that enable RNA
seek data to be efficiently mapped to an
organism's genome assembly in order to
produce RNA seek data we need to first
obtain and sequence the RNA from the
organism we are studying RNA can be
extracted from an organism at specific
developmental stages from specific
tissues or after different treatments
the extracted RNAs undergo library
preparation and are most often sequenced
using the Illumina sequencing technology
we call the sequence data obtained from
sequencing a fragment of RNA or read in
general reads produced by the Illumina
sequencers are between 75 and 150 bases
long the resulting RNA seek data allow
us to identify genes that are expressed
and to identify genes that show changes
in expression levels under different
conditions after the sequence data have
been obtained we need to map the RNA
seek reads to the genome so that we can
determine the genes that are being
expressed this is a difficult
computational problem the sizes of the
genome assembly for eukaryotes can range
from tens of millions to tens of
billions of bases and the Illumina
sequencer can produce hundreds of
millions of RNA seek reads in addition
because of sequencing errors and
polymorphisms we need to allow for a
small number of differences between the
RNA seek reads and the genome assembly
if we were to use an algorithm like
Plast to perform this search the process
would be extremely slow because the
amount of time required to search each
RNA seek read would be proportional to
the length of the database hence we must
use an
alternative approach that reduces the
amount of time required to search for
sequence similarity between each RNA
read and the genome assembly this
alternative approach takes advantage of
a data structure in computer science
known as a suffix tree the suffix tree
creates an index of the genome assembly
thereby allowing us to quickly find the
locations where the RNA seek read
matches the genome assembly we will use
a simple example to illustrate how to
construct a suffix tree our database
consists of a sequence of DNA with 10
nucleotides
we will first specify the position of
each base in the sequence starting from
position 0 the dollar sign at position
10 denotes the end of the sequence to
help us construct a suffix tree we will
first create a suffix array each element
in the suffix array corresponds to a
position in the DNA sequence and it's
corresponding suffix for example at
position 10 the suffix is the dollar
sign at position 9 suffix is an a
followed by the dollar sign the suffix G
a dollar sign is at position 8 the
suffix AG a dollar sign is at position 7
and so on we can continue to build this
list backwards until we reach position 0
where the suffix is the entire DNA
sequence in the database we then sort
these suffixes alphabetically while also
keeping track of the position of each
suffix we can convert a suffix array
into a suffix tree by merging the common
suffixes in the list of sorted suffixes
we will examine each column of the
suffix array and create a separate
branch for each unique nucleotide for
example in the first column of the
suffix array we have the nucleotides a C
and G hence we will create 3 branches in
the first level of the tree for the
subset of suffixes that begin with an A
the second column consists of the dollar
sign C and G this
means we will create three branches at
the second level of the tree when we
reach the dollar sign we will record the
position in the leaf of the tree in this
case we will record the position 9 for
the suffix a dollar sign we can repeat
this process to construct the rest of
the sub tree for the suffixes that begin
with an A similarly we can repeat this
process to construct the sub trees for
the suffixes that begin with a C or a G
after we have created the suffix tree it
now becomes much easier to find all the
matches to a read in the database for
example if we want to find the sequence
C AG in our database we simply follow
the branches of the tree until we match
the entire read and report the positions
in the leads in this case positions 1
and 6 the amount of time required to
find all matches to a read is
proportional to the logarithm of the
length of the read and does not depend
on the size of the database we can
modify the search algorithm to allow in
exact matches to allow base
substitutions we can follow multiple
paths but charge a penalty for each
mismatch we can terminate the search
within a sub tree once the number of
mismatches exceeds the maximum number of
differences allowed to facilitate
inexact matches with insertions and
deletions we can use dynamic programming
or a heuristic search to compute the
edit distance of the read against many
paths in the suffix tree